الان من بيكيين السيد نادي رونج اخوان همم
الصحفي والاعلاميه الصين في مجموعه الصين
للاعلام اهلا ومرحبا بك على فرنسا
بدايه ما هي قراءتك لهذه الاحتجاجات التي
شهدتها الصين خلال الساعات الاخيره وهل
نحن امام حركه غير مسبوقه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
التنفيذ
السياسات
[موسيقى]
وهذا ما يسبب الى غدا بعد المواطنين وكذلك
الذي سبب ال- همم هناك همم بعد ثلاثه
سنوات هناك يعني تكاليف اجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه همم
سيد هارت على الوباء ومن اجل ايضا دوما ان
الحياه المواطنين فااا حاليا
الحكومه تعمل على تحسين المستمر لهذه
اجراءات وكذلك يعني
مساعده المسؤولين في
استخدام
السلطاتهم وكذلك
الحكومه بتاع المواطنين الى ال همم
يعني وقف على في شكل عقلاني وهمم كذلك
التفاهم مع همم الحديث السياسه هناك ايضا
همم الدعوات الاخرى يعني من المواطنين
كذلك للحفاظ على الاستقرار وهمم يعني
الدفاع عند همم
حقوق حقوقهم وفي نفس الوقت يعني حسب
القانون وفي نفس الوقت معرضه
طيب قوه الامن الصينيه سارعت الى تفريق
المحتاجين وهناك انباء ايضا تفيد بتوقيف
عدد من
المتظاهرين في عدد من المدن يعني همم كيف
تتوقع ان تتطور الامور خلال الساعات
القليله المقبله
ستعود الى المسار عيد الطبيعيه لان همم
ظهر كثير من الدعوات كذلك الى الحفاظ على
الاستكرار الاجتماعيه وما عارضه الشغب
وكذلك تم اعلان سلسله من رئيس
المشاكل لحل مثلا توصيل الى
المستشفى
والعدويه يعني تقليل المشاكل او التسهيل
الحياه المواطنين اكبر قدر البنك
على الكثير من الاحياء السكنيه اليوم
فاعتقد ان هذا يعني همم الحياه ستعود الى
طبيعتها
اذا انت تستبعد الاستمرار هذه الحركه
الاحتجاجيه ضد هذه القيود
وسياسه الاخلاق التي تفرضها السلطات في
عدد من الدول الصينيه من المدن السعوديه
[موسيقى]